le bocage normand est en ébullition les
petits fabricants de camembert veulent
par tous les moyens préserver leur
appellation de fabrication au lait cru
en fait ils accusent les industriels de
l'agroalimentaire d'assassiner un
monument de la gastronomie en utilisant
des techniques de chauffage ou de
filtrage du lait la guerre des
étiquettes et des labels et lancé
françois jullien pieds noirs
philippe chasselas c'est la révolution
en normandie
partisan du camembert au lait cru contre
camembert au lait chauffé ou fixe dans
cette ferme pas question de toucher au
symbole de la france on suit la même
recette depuis des générations
le camembert c'est au lait cru
on essaie de défendre au maximum nous
notre produit puis se croit le le
camembert de normandie doit être
fabriquée avec du lait cru sinon on sort
de l'appellation est justement ce grand
groupe a perdu l'appellation d'origine
contrôlée car ici on micro filtre le
lait pour enlever les bactéries un
sacrilège pour les puristes ce n'est
plus du lait cru donc plus d'un aussi
mais pour ce fabricant filetées diminue
les risques de maladies et puis ça
permet d'exporter le camembert aux états
unis où l'on a peur du lait cru nous on
considère qu'un risque entre 2 et 3%
grâce à la microfiltration cela vous
permet d'avoir les deux aspects c'est à
dire la sécurité alimentaire et le goût
du camembert de normandie
on voulait faire un petit test et nous y
en a qui est au lait cru l'autre qu'il
n'est pas sur un marché normand on ne
rigole pas avec le goût du camembert à
gauche un aoc au lait cru
à droite un micro filtré alors je
penserai consulat on les fout lui faire
perdre et c'est celui-ci est que les
trouver les crues père de dommages mais
il y en a une
qu'on ne trompe pas c'est la fromagère
les crues
on panique alors ceux qui chauffent et
qui filtrent le lait souhaiteraient
changer les critères de l'appellation
pour récupérer la hausse et co2 question
pour les défenseurs du véritable
camembert de normandie
pour nous c'est le lait qui fait le bout
du camembert qui fait qui fait la saveur
du camembert
si on chauffe le lit on n'a plus cette
saveur donc c'est plus de camembert
alors
qui l'eût cru qu'un jour en normandie on
se serait fait la guerre somme toute
sans se taper dessus
non pas pour un bout de terre mais pour
un goût de camembert